today on the matt wall show a report
about rampant child porn on pornhub has
prompted the site to make
quote major changes but the changes
don't go nearly far enough
also five headlines including eric
swalwell's ties to a chinese spy
and dozens of shoppers camp out in the
walmart parking lot
to buy a new video game console why is
that okay during a pandemic but you
still can't visit your grandparents for
christmas or thanksgiving
and our daily cancellation we will
cancel a school board that voted to
remove thomas jefferson's name
from their elementary school the reasons
they give
i mean you know that they're going to be
bad reasons these are truly deeply
insane reasons
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
before we get started uh today you know
if you if you're on the internet
which you are right now probably and i'm
sure you spend a lot of time on it as we
all do
you need a vpn to protect yourself
everybody absolutely everybody
needs a vpn i mean does it make sense to
you that the same company who controls
half of online retail
also eavesdrops passively on your
private conversations at home
what about the idea that a single
company controls 90 of internet searches
runs
runs your email service gets to track
everything you do on a smartphone
big tech is is the fact is more powerful
than most countries are
and they profit the way they get so
powerful is by exploiting your personal
data
it's uh i think it's time to put a layer
of protection it's way past that put a
layer of protection between
your online activity and these tech
juggernauts and that's why i personally
use expressvpn and you should too
think about how much of your life is on
the internet you know how much of your
of your life
you you willingly how much of your
personal information you've willingly
given over to the internet
and how much the internet has has helped
itself to and taken
it's just it's a lot but when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn
makes your activity harder to trace and
harder to sell to advertisers and again
it gives you that layer of protection
that you need and you deserve
expressvpn does all of this without
showing uh your connection
that's why it's rated the number one vpn
or rather without slowing your
connections it's not going to slow
everything down
some vpns will the expressvpn doesn't do
that
and that's why it's really the number
one vpn service by cnet and wired
what i like most about expressvpn is
that it's very easy to use if it was
hard to use i wouldn't be able to do it
the fact that i use it
means that that you can do it and you
should do it so
stop handing your personal data over to
these big tech monopolies that mine your
activity and sell your information
protect yourself
with the vpn i trust keep me safe online
visit expressvpn.com walsh that's
[Music]
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh to get three extra months free
again that's expressvpn.com
walsh go there now to learn more the new
york times uh committed a
shocking act of actual journalism this
week when
they published a lengthy op-ed titled
the children of pornhub columnist
nicholas kristoff uh calls attention to
an issue that earlier in the year was
the subject of a petition that amassed
nearly half a million signatures
namely that the behemoth smut site
traffics and child pornography rape
videos
and other forms of abuse and then of
course
films and uploads them for public
viewing
kristoff writes quote pornhub is
infested with rape videos
it monetizes child rapes revenge
pornography spy cam videos of women
showering
racist and misogynistic content footage
of women being asphyxiated in plastic
bags
a search for quote girls under 18 no
space or
14 yo which 14 years old leads in each
case to more than 100 thousand videos
most aren't of children being assaulted
but too many are
now we should emphasize that even if a
preponderance of
the videos found using these search
terms do not actually depict children
being raped
a sizable portion do depict it as he
mentions and all
and also almost as troubling a
significant portion of the
non-rape videos found through these
search keys
are still meant to appeal to people who
want to see
children being raped the point is that
even the videos on the platform
that do not involve child abuse or rape
may still
desensitize the viewer to child abuse
and rape and intentionally so
pornhub itself proudly tells us that one
of its most popular categories
is teen okay are we supposed to believe
that the grown men huddled around their
computers and darkened rooms
looking for videos of teens are really
hoping only to see 18 and 19 year olds
no they want to see young women or girls
disrobe and perform sexually for their
enjoyment
their concern about the actual ages of
the people on the screen extends only so
far as providing them plausible
deniability
should the fbi come knocking terms like
teen
and barely legal are workarounds you
know sort of a wink
between pornhub and its users the site
feeds an appetite for illegal porn even
with its legal porn
but that shouldn't distract from the
fact that there is a lot of the straight
up illegal stuff on the platform
and there are very real victims to tell
the tale here's a little more from
kristoff he says pornhub
quoting now from a woman named cali
pornhub became my trafficker
she said she was adopted in the united
states from china and then trafficked by
her adoptive family and forced to appear
in pornographic videos beginning when
she was nine
some videos of her of her being abused
ended up on pornhub and regularly
reappear there she said
cali said i'm still getting sold even
though i'm five years out of that life
now 23 she
now 23 she is studying in a university
hoping to become a lawyer
but those old videos hang over her i may
never be able to get away from this you
said
i may be 40 with kids with eight kids
and people are still masturbating to my
photos
you type young asian and you can
probably find me
she added kristoff then notes that a
search for young asian
returns tens of thousands of videos
along with related search
suggestions such as young tiny teen and
also
young girl there's a whole channel
called exploited teen asia
now i suppose we're meant we're meant to
believe that the people looking for
young girls and young tiny teens or
clicking on video compilations with
titles like
screaming teen degraded teen extreme
choking
all examples mentioned in the article
are really only interested in seeing
sober willing adults engaged in
consensual sexual relations
and we're further supposed to believe
that the users uploading this content
with these sorts of titles are only
providing that sort of legal and above
the board content
but anybody who really buys that claim
must have already had their brain melted
but melted by porn over consumption
the fact is clear pornhub makes untold
millions
monetizing child porn and rape videos
and it's not an accident
there is a huge market for this stuff
and pornhub
serves that market but a fun
funny thing happened after the times
piece was published
in the immediate aftermath a spokesman
for the company sent a statement to the
national review
indignantly indignantly denying that
they had any serious problem with rape
and abuse videos on their platform
the statement said in part quote any
assertion that we allow
csam child sexual abuse material is
irresponsible and flagrantly untrue
we have zero tolerance for csam pornhub
is unequivocally committed to
combating csam and has instituted an
industry-leading trust and safety policy
to identify and eradicate illegal
material from our community
they also claim to manually review every
video posted to the site
a claim that itself must certainly be
flagrantly untrue
as pornhub also boasts proudly that
users uploaded nearly three hours of
porn
per minute last year
but only a day later pornhub changed its
tune
rather dramatically perhaps having
something to do with the fact that
mastercard and visa said they'd be
quote reviewing their relationship with
the filth peddlers
the company announced suddenly that it
would be taking major steps quote
unquote to quote protect
our community i thought they were
already doing an excellent job in that
regard according to their own statement
not but 24 hours earlier
how can you take major steps to better
do something
that you're already doing nearly
perfectly these major steps include
limiting uploads to verified users only
prohibiting most downloads from the site
and also expanding moderation of the
content
again it's hard to understand how they
could expand their moderation
if they were already manually reviewing
something like
1.5 million hours of pornography a year
the conflicting messaging though only
makes sense when you remember that
this is a billion this is a
multi-billion dollar company that makes
its billions
distributing videos with titles like
young tiny teen and extreme choking
a company that will let you search for
porn using a search term like
14 year old in other words they have no
ethical standards of any kind whatsoever
and nothing they say can be remotely
trusted
their statements and commitments and
declarations of how seriously they want
to protect rape victims etc
mean nothing after all if they really
cared about protecting victims
they would just shut down operations
entirely
a porn distributor claiming a commitment
to combating sex
trafficking is about as credible as all
the tobacco companies now saying that
they want to
help rid the world of nicotine addiction
this is the script
they have to read but it cannot possibly
be true
their very existence testifies to the
falsehood of their claims
besides the measures from pornhub are
laughably insufficient
even if they're actually adopted which
they won't be
what's to stop a verified user from
uploading a video of an underage person
or someone who's been sex trafficked or
somebody who's unconscious or
not consenting the the verified user
gambit
is also especially unconvincing because
the bar for verification is low
as the website fight the new drug notes
all a person has to do to get verified
on pornhub
is upload a photo of themselves with
their or a photo of someone
with their pornhub username and
pornhub's website written on a piece of
paper or their body
there's no attempt to verify age much
less that of all the performers quote
unquote in the video
in the videos themselves this is just
verifying something really verifying
nothing about the person uploading the
video doesn't tell you anything
about the people in the video
while the efforts to protect the people
in the videos is
virtually non-existent the efforts to
protect the people
watching the videos are literally
non-existent
pornhub makes no attempt to prevent
children from accessing the hardcore
filth on its platform
no attempt at all they don't do anything
to visit budweiser.com you could try
this yourself
you at least have to enter your date of
birth if you want to go to the official
camel cigarette website
you need to register for an account to
sign up for a bitcoin exchange like
bitfinex a user has to provide their
address phone number email and two forms
of government if you
issued identification now surveying the
options
on the spectrum between the symbolic age
verification of a beer company's website
to the serious verification process of a
crypto exchange
pornhub elects to do precisely nothing
they don't choose anything
they don't even do this symbolic attempt
any random eight-year-old can go to its
url
and watch gangbang videos without having
to jump through
any hoops at all this gives you an idea
of how serious pornhub is about
protecting anyone
least of all children and this is why we
have to stop relying
on the integrity and good hearts of
executives at porn sites
trusting them to make good on their word
to self-regulate
we should force the issue just like we
do with all the regulations imposed on
the alcohol and tobacco industry
people don't normally complain about
that no one ever i rarely hear anyone
complain
that a that uh you know an 11 year old
can't walk to 7-eleven and buy a pack of
cigarettes
nobody complains that this is a this is
a nanny state or an intrusion or
anything like that
now i confess i would be in favor of
simply burning the porn industry to the
ground
salting the earth with it with his ashes
um but in lieu of that
pornhub and all sites like it should be
legally required
to verify the ages of all users at a
minimum
those uploading content and those
viewing the content
if you want to buy a porn magazine from
a gas station
if that's even so possible anymore you
have to show id
there is no reason why you shouldn't
have to show one online
and don't tell me about oh it's the
parent's job okay yeah
the parents should be doing more to
protect their own kids but again
if if if a nine-year-old walks up with a
hustler magazine to buy uh
to buy a you know to to the cashier at a
gas station
would you be okay with the cashier just
selling it to him on the basis that well
his parents aren't doing anything about
it might as well just make a buck
no there should be at least the same uh
level of scrutiny placed on
pornhub as there is on gas stations
now it's true such a requirement may
destroy pornhub
as most of its users would be too
ashamed and freaked out to give their id
to a porn site
that is a risk that i am more than happy
to take now the government could go even
further and should as terry schilling
outlines in his excellent first things
essay published
i think earlier in the year you should
check it out he talks about what we
could do to regulate porn he says we
could have zoning laws requiring porn
sites to move to a dot xx domain where
age verification would be needed to
access it more aggressively congress
could amend section 230 of the
communications decency act
getting rid of the blanket immunity
enjoyed by big tech companies
and holding them liable for the content
posted on their platforms
this would mean that a sex trafficking
or revenge porn victim
could sue pornhub for hosting and
monetizing the footage of their abuse
why shouldn't they be able to sue
if it doesn't seem possible for a
massive
multi-billion dollar porn platform to
really regulate its content
and guard against child porn and rape
porn
that might be a sign that massive
multi-billion dollar porn platforms
shouldn't exist
the only real downside to regulating
porn companies as far as i can see it
is that it might make porn executives a
little less rich
and it might it might cause some mild
inconveniences for internet users who
want to watch other people having sex
these are trade-offs that i think a
society can live with indeed trade-offs
that we should embrace enthusiastically
in exchange for offering at least some
protection
to the porn industry's many victims on
both
sides of the camera
and it's as simple as that as far as i'm
concerned
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right um now we get to our uh five
headlines as we pull it up here i got a
bunch of clips to play today but before
we get to
any of those here's a report from the
daily wire
representative eric swalwell sits on the
sensitive house intelligence committee
said in response to an explosive story
about ties to a suspected chinese spy
that quote congressional leaders knew
about it
they knew about the matter and implied
that they apparently did not think that
it was a big enough issue to keep him
off the intelligence committee
the alleged spy chinese national
christine feng
targeted up and coming local politicians
in the bay area and across the country
had the potential to make it big on the
national stage
through campaign fundraising extensive
networking personal charisma
and romantic or sexual relationships
this according to a report from axios
even though u.s officials do not believe
fang received or passed on classified
information
the case was a big deal because there
were some really really sensitive people
that were caught up in the intelligence
network according to a current senior
u.s intel intelligence official yeah i
would say it's a big deal
i would call that a big deal um
when you've got a congressman who was
potentially involved with the chinese
spy
this again you know we we find this this
pattern playing out where
the people who were accusing
the trump campaign of this sort of thing
with relation to china were actually
doing it themselves
we see this over and over again yet
another guy
who was railing about um
about uh donald trump and russia is
supposed to
suppose it ties to russian espionage
that whole time he's got this uh
some sort of acquaintance with a with a
chinese spy
um you know that of course is a big
story
big big uh big should be big blowback
for for eric swalwell
at a minimum i still don't think
it's as big of a story as eric swalwall
farting on camera during the msnbc
interview that to me is well here's what
i'll say
that is what will still ultimately
define him and i'm glad for that
it's that's not as big of a scandal but
i'm i'm happy for the fact
that this just absolute mediocre
unimpressive
empty nothing of a man will ultimately
be defined
by the fact that he farted on camera
that's that's all his entire public life
will come down to and i really i hope
it's more that than the chinese spy
thing
um okay biden so biden's got his
covid task force together and i want to
play some of this dr
marcella nunes smith
um she's one of the people on the biden
coveted task force
and she's found and we're gonna get a
lot of this
um from the potential by the
administration
we're gonna get a lot of of of of course
racializing everything like the left
always does
she's found a way to racialize the
covent pandemic and
identifying what she calls a racial
grief gap you've heard of the wage gap
well here is the
grief gap listen it is not a coincidence
and it is not a matter of genetics that
more than 70 percent
of african americans and more than 60
percent of latinx americans
personally know someone who has been
hospitalized
or died from coven 19.
the same disparities ingrained in our
economy
our housing system our food system our
justice system
and so many other areas of our society
have conspired
in this moment to create a grief gap
that we cannot ignore yeah she says it's
not it's not a coincidence i mean you're
right it's not a coincidence there's a
reason behind it
as we hear about how you know uh racial
minorities are disproportionately
uh affected by by covid and
infected by by the virus the reason
is that racial minorities are
disproportionately live in cities
um and so that's the reason and and when
when you live in a city and there's a a
large population
condensed population population
densities is high
they're going to have more spread of of
a virus
that's the reason it's not there's no
there's no nefarious racism behind it
i'm not even sure you know you hear this
this this implied from people like
dr marcela here implying that there's
racism behind
it that you know more more black people
are getting a disproportionate number of
black people are getting coveted
oh it's it's racist she never explains
how
how exactly is it racist what what what
exactly are you implying
she never gets there she just throws it
out and of course we get the latinx
thing too
that that is another thing with a
potential biden administration
we have to get ready for that that we're
going to hear this latin x thing
from bureaucrats in the federal
government all the time
now of course you talk to any latino
person
or most of them and i and i have asked i
mean this i put a poll out on twitter
recently asking any um any hispanic
followers of mine how they feel about
this latinx thing
and what you find unsurprisingly it's
almost all just white liberals
or non-white liberals in this case who
are doing latinx
and also by the way it should be
pronounced latinx
so first of all can we decide is it
latinx or latin x
but either way it's utterly ridiculous
these are
non-hispanic liberals trying to impose
this change on the hispanic community
and the hispanic community for the most
part says what no
by the way if you really if for some
reason latino or latina
offends you or upsets you what's wrong
with just saying latin
what do you even need the ex for
of course i'm trying to make sense of
something that that is nonsensical so
maybe there's no point in doing that
now we've got bill nye here bill nye is
uh begging for attention again
probably we shouldn't give it to him but
here we are
and here's the video let's watch here's
a map of the united states the red ink
shows where people
are wearing masks the black ink
shows where people are getting sick with
coronavirus
i hope you can see the fewer the mass
the more the sex
and there's a perception that a virus
can travel through the fibers of a mask
like this red dot
because viruses don't travel by
themselves now they travel into
droplets of spit and snot
and the fibers are a tangle so when the
droplet gets into the fibers of a mask
it gets trapped this is not that hard to
understand everybody
that's why we have rules about wearing a
mask
now you know about rules you pay taxes
on the whole road but you only get to
drive on one side at a time
otherwise so everyone please
wear a mask thank you every time we see
bill nye we have to remember
that he goes by the science guy for a
reason
it's not just that it rhymes with nye uh
it's because he's not a scientist
so that's you anyone can call themselves
a i'm i'm matt walsh the science guy
anyone could call yourself that i'm sure
i like science too i'm a science guy
um so he's not a scientist he's a
science guy which means nothing at all
but i i keep you keep hearing this this
this claim from people like bill nye
everybody else on the left democrats uh
we keep hearing this claim that you know
we've got that we've got the new surge
uh because people aren't wearing the
masks
and and that's why the the virus is
surging again
where is that the case because
everywhere i go i mean this is all
anecdotal but everyone must be just be
basing this on anecdotal evidence
so my own anecdotal experience almost
everywhere i go people are wearing the
masks
certainly a large a large large number
of people are wearing the masks
red states blue states i have traveled
quite a bit during the
cover 19 pandemic forgive me i have and
everywhere i've gone people wearing the
masks
it's it's actually shocking how many
people wear them and how consistently
and how you know the one thing that i
notice especially on planes now
because you're sitting around people uh
for you know hours at a time
and when i look around i people don't
even fidget with the mask
i don't even see that many people
anymore putting the mask underneath
their nose i still do that so i can
breathe
but most people they just have it over
their nose they don't touch it
they have it on right and they keep it
on for hours at a time
it's it's creepy um but that's what
people are doing
and yet the virus is still surging
maybe there's a connection here
something to think about
finally uh i probably enjoyed this a
little bit more than i should here's
a local news report out of troy michigan
about a bunch of grown adults
who lined up all night in frigid
temperatures this is michigan
remember it is december now and they
lined up all night outside of a walmart
for a video game console only to be
severely disappointed when the walmart
actually opened
watch this so the rumor was that walmart
here in troy had the playstation 5. it's
one of the hottest items for this
holiday season well
word got out and about 100 people
started lining up at about midnight
yes sir look at this how long you guys
how many days you guys tried to get this
playstation for 12 hours 12
hours you've been here yes sir why is it
so important to get one of these
we need them when the doors open a
stampede of people went into the store
led by foddy from troy and people are
wanting to get in
look at this look at this but only to
find out that walmart had no
ps5s that's according to the manager
right foddy
uh she comes on and tells us that they
have none in stock so if we were told
that they're gonna have in the stock
monday and we waited seven hours on the
freezing cold of 28 degrees
why is there zero stock okay
uh that's uh that's good you know what
serves you right
serves your right this is how you decide
to spend your night
waiting in a walmart parking lot for 12
hours
how do you not call the walmart first
that's my question
now we were told in the report that a
rumor there was a rumor
they heard from somewhere how before you
even
think about getting your tent out and
can't be
how do you not just call them and say
hey are you getting the ps5s in
no but apparently nobody did that they
just i don't know they were driving by
they saw other people waiting
what are you guys waiting for oh we're
we we've been waiting for 12 hours for a
ps5 well i guess i will too then
and then they run in and there's no ps5
they have to be escorted out by police
officer
so many questions arise for me when i
see this
um first question is why just why in
general
i i have i have never wanted
a consumer product enough to wait even
an hour for it
i've never seen an hour-long wait for
anything
where i actually said to myself oh i'm
i'll do that that's worth it
if i see and this is why i won't go to
this my wife tries to
go to disney world i won't go to disney
world i won't go to amusement parks
even like a even like a five minute wait
you need
that needs to really be justified it has
to really really be worth it an
hour hell no i'm not waiting for for a
thing a product
especially when i know that okay i can
just order it online what are you doing
you just order it online you have to
wait a couple more weeks
um so that's that's the first question i
have
and then the second question though
maybe more more pertinent
is is uh this is in michigan
and we're not not only is it like 20
degrees overnight
but very strict with the covet
restrictions there in michigan
you know that's definitely one of those
states where they're telling you no more
than 10 people
don't visit your your grandmother or
thanksgiving and christmas
so you know you can't get together with
your family over the holiday
um they're shutting down all these you
know all these indoor establishments
yet a hundred people can huddle together
outside of a walmart to buy a
video game console they weren't even
wearing masks did you notice that
normally that wouldn't bother me i don't
care if you wear a mask or not
but no police shut the police only
showed up when walmart called them to
escort the people out of the building
because i guess they were
they were they were disgruntled over the
fact that there was no
there's no ps5 that's amazing to me
or it's not really amazing because we're
used to this sort of uh this sort of
hypocrisy by now but it should be
amazing
it's what we've discovered you know it's
the this um
this immunity enjoyed by shoppers at b
big retail outlets continues i guess
if you're shopping at walmart for
consumer products
you're immune just like if you're
marching for
racial equity you're immune you're
celebrating
joe biden you're immune um you're going
to the funeral
of a of a of a passed away democrat
or someone who or or someone was shot by
police you're immune
really incredible scientifically maybe
bill nye the science guy can explain the
science behind that because i i gotta
admit i'm pretty stupid
i don't fully understand it myself but
there is maybe they can check
maybe just order it on amazon and wait
at your house
maybe while you're waiting for the ps5
it might take a few weeks i guess
uh maybe you could think about
developing a hobby of some kind that
doesn't involve sitting on your couch
just a suggestion now before we get to
our daily cancellation
um with the new year coming up christmas
coming up how about give yourself
a present give yourself a gift uh with a
daily wire membership and now now's the
time to do it a lot of great stuff
coming up
we have a lot of great stuff right now
that you could take advantage of
like this left this is the new and
improved um
leftist tears tumbler and uh you know
what
coffee's been sitting there for about
two days but uh i won't blame the time
to learn that this this top this tumbler
is
is wonderful it keeps the coffee even
though it's been sitting there
for days it's still somewhat lukewarm
and uh
and it tastes horrible but the tumbler
is still great on top of that though
you get with the membership you get so
much more uh
we're adding a lot of content to the
daily wire michael knowles show
is now five days a week adding more
content for our members to enjoy we're
adding the entire prageru catalogue to
dailywire.com by the end of the year
we've already got the
prageru's five-minute videos uploaded
we've got the candace owen show from
prageru
michael knowles is book club the rest of
the library will be added
soon it's being added as we speak so
more and more every time you go there's
more stuff
and early next year candace owens is
joining the daily wire here in nashville
she's going to be launching a live
studio audience show
that's going to be great we're building
we've been telling you about the
investigative journalism team uh they're
we're making movies we're doing so much
you got to become a member
dailywire.com subscribe
we're loud and opinionated having a good
time and i'm having a great time
actually today
change of pace because i have just been
informed the big news
today is the last day that you can buy
the daily wire christmas tree ornaments
they have just been sitting
lonely in a warehouse because nobody
wants them
but if you've been if you have been
putting it off if you've been
procrastinating
and you've been telling yourself every
day i've got to buy the i got to buy the
ornaments so i can have
matt walsh and michael knowles and ben
shapiro and jeremy boring has adorable
christmas christmas tree elves
christmas elves on my christmas tree
you've been putting it off now is the
time you got to do it
this is the last day that i will have to
talk about that
uh text christmas to 83400 to get your
tree decorated
or don't it doesn't really matter to me
but this is your last chance to do it
again that's eight three four
zero zero text christmas now all right
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're canceling the falls church
school board in virginia
on tuesday the school board voted
unanimously to change the names of
thomas jefferson elementary school in
george mason high school achieving
what i think is one of the great feats
of bureaucratic cowardice
by knocking out the father of the bill
of rights and the author of declaration
of independence all at once
in one evening school board chair greg
anderson
in announcing the change said quote the
board took seriously the viewpoints and
concerns raised by many students parents
staff and community members
we thank everyone who shared their
perspectives with us and will be mindful
of their comments as we now begin
selecting names that reflect the
diversity of opinions in our community
our schools must be places where all
students staff community members
feel safe supported and inspired
contrary to mr anderson's blatherings
here the viewpoints of anybody who
claims to feel
unsafe because an elementary school is
named after thomas jefferson
should not be taken seriously a person
who raises such concerns
should be summarily dismissed as
mentally ill
stupid insincere or some combination of
the above
their opinions on the issue are not
important their feelings don't matter
their desire to dethrone our greatest
national heroes
should not be treated with even a
modicum of respect
but that's how it should be and we know
that how it should be and how it is
are two different things especially
these days a report from the local falls
church news press
says that the board was making the move
out of respect for the
strongly felt sentiments of students
teachers and citizens although adults
it's also
it also notes that a majority of that
group student teacher citizens
didn't want the name to be changed
the board members ultimately caved to
the demands of the unreasonable minority
as it often goes
it takes a special sort of coward to
make
this sort of decision under those
circumstances
and footage from a school board work
session in june when they first began
talking about this issue
shows that the board is indeed occupied
by those sorts of cowards
the members can be seen babbling
semi-coherently about equity and
inclusion
none of them seeming too terribly
excited about the name change
but none possessing the minimal courage
required to speak up decisively against
it
this is how bureaucracies from the local
school school board all the way up to
the federal government
often wind up making mind-numbingly
terrible decisions
not everybody involved has to be radical
ideologues there are usually only a few
of those
the rest just have to be so spineless
that you wonder how they manage to sit
up straight in their chairs
and that's certainly the case here let's
uh let's let's take a look at some of
that
work session listen here um deeply held
concerns about george mason
thomas jefferson as owners of enslaved
people
have led a lot of folks to push for a
new name um
for one or more of our schools you know
long-standing racism
inequities they're being denounced and
they're being fought on a scale that we
haven't seen in decades
i had a debate with myself whether i
should say within my lifetime because i
wasn't sure if i really wanted to
to say that out loud but there you go
certainly in decades and people across
the country are looking to themselves to
each other and to their elected leaders
to
make the changes that are needed thank
you chair anderson
uh i agree with um everything that you
said i think
you know there are um this i consider
myself a pretty decisive person but this
is definitely something that i have kept
an open mind on and i definitely
see uh both sides of this issue and i do
feel that
um it's it's an important one i agree
with i think
almost everything you said i also
support the
notion of starting a process um
i i think the question is far from clear
certainly in my mind and in the
community's mind
because we are talking about two people
in this case two men
um who have mixed legacies who
accomplished a lot but
um uh clearly owned slaves
and that's an extremely hard thing um to
forget
and you can't forget or really forgive
you can just perhaps understand
what uh just an absolute parade of
mediocrity
we just witnessed there especially the
first all of them
but especially the first guy he makes
the perfect
cowardly bureaucratic type of dude uh
chair of the school board nothing going
on at all
yes we care about uh diversity and
inclusion and uh
people have different opinions and uh
everyone's opinions uh
are valid and some people have an
opinion that says
one thing and others have opinions that
say another and everyone has good
opinions and
opinions are all good tolerance is good
diversity diversity is very very good
we we value diversity just shut up dude
say something can you say it can you
string together a sentence that means
anything i don't care what it is
are you capable of that probably not
but all the wimpish waffling and
platitude spewing
eventually gave way to a decision the
wrong one as expected
one of the school board members philip
wrightinger
and you you just saw him at the end of
that clip and explaining his vote during
the meeting on tuesday night
inadvertently provided i think a master
class in orwellian rationalization
reading from his prepared remarks
reitinger says that he decided to vote
for changing the name
partly because donald trump put kids in
cages
now it's not clear why thomas jefferson
should be blamed for the
immigrant detention policies instituted
by obama or even why donald trump should
be blamed for them
um all right could say was that trump's
alleged bigotry had led him to conclude
that the board had to do more for
diversity he also implied though
that having a school named after
jefferson and mason makes a statement
that people are not created equal and
then he claimed
that the best way to live up to the
words of thomas jefferson
is to quote no longer have a school
named after him
you have to hear this for yourself take
take a listen but i will vote to change
the names
i believe that at this time in this
place
it is the right thing to do the critical
moment for me was the presidential
election
i know this is a non-partisan board but
i hold political views
and those views are affected by my
values just as were the presidential
candidates views affected by their
values
i was proud that in the falls church
city the democratic candidate whose
views favor equity and inclusion won
with over 81 percent of the vote
however outside a false church
approaching half the country
voted for the other candidate that
candidate put children
in cages he said there were good people
among the white supremacists
marching in charlottesville he stoked
division at
every turn i am appalled both by his
behavior and what the vote means for the
country
i feel the need both personally and in
my capacity
as a member of the falls church city
school board to help change our course
and do more for diversity and inclusion
we need to fight inequality and racism
with action
we need to speak out although actions
matter more than words
words matter by having schools named for
george mason and thomas jefferson we are
making a statement
and i think we should make a different
statement
we should instead make a statement that
we believe all people
are created equal thomas jefferson wrote
almost those very words and we can
better live up to the goal he
set by no longer having a school named
for him
amazing amazing by the way i i
i just noticed watching that clip back
that
two of the people there uh anderson the
the school chair that we heard from
earlier
and then one of the other guys has the
pronouns up on the zoom call for next to
their name they got the he him
of course of course they do of course
they do
and you know as i've said before um
if if you if you are so often mistaken
for a woman
that you have to specify to everybody
that you meet that by the way i'm a man
that that's that's a separate issue you
might want to look into you could
you might even talk to your doctor about
that um you know
maybe testosterone pills or something
might might be
might be a good idea to look into uh you
know what i find is that
i don't have to go up to people and say
i'm matt walsh he him
because they they sort of like just get
it by looking at me they get the he him
part
but not the case for everybody and i can
see how it wouldn't be the case for greg
anderson
in any case um there we have that we
have writing journey he's appalled
he's appalled appalled by donald trump
and for some reason he's appalled by
donald trump
for a bunch of stuff that isn't even
true and the way to solve that
is to take it out on thomas jefferson
now the cowardly coup de grace
came later that night when the school
formerly known as thomas jefferson
elementary
perhaps we could take the washington
football team approach and rename the
school simply
the elementary school tweeted out the
news of the name change
and then deleted it as soon as people
started criticizing it
you know the schools have made their
decision now they're just going to hide
under their beds until the me until the
mean people stop yelling at them about
it
as it happens the board members are able
to hide under their beds or in their
beds
because schools in falls church have
been shut down since spring of last year
they recently voted to extend the remote
learning farce until 2021 at least so
while students remain abandoned in limbo
having not received a real education in
nine months the board has spent its time
conducting a moral assessment
of a founding father who died 200 years
ago
that's what they're doing with their
time needless to say their moral
assessment is wrong
yes thomas jefferson owns slaves so did
george mason these were flawed men
but their flaws were nearly ubiquitous
in their time
not everybody owned slaves of course but
i doubt whether any single person
on earth in the year 1776 or any year
before it
or even in the century after it could
have passed as racially enlightened by
our standards today
most of the world still cannot pass that
test
and many people in the world still own
slaves in fact just not in the western
world
in jefferson's time his perspective was
about as enlightened as it got
and that's how he and george mason
that's you know and and their
compatriots
managed to lay the groundwork for what
would soon become
the greatest not to mention most diverse
and racially tolerant
country on earth we honor the founding
fathers
for that great achievement we don't
honor them because they were perfect
we honor them because we are americans
this is america
and they are the men who built it that
should be reason enough
if it's not reason enough then no
historical figure is safe
none great people often commit
great sins martin luther king jr
was allegedly a serial philanderer who
watched and laughed as a woman was raped
if we cannot put thomas jefferson's bad
choices into context then why should we
lend that grace to mlk
if we're looking for a perfect hero
among mere mortal men
anywhere on earth anywhere in history we
will not find him
even if we're searching simply for
somebody who wouldn't be called racist
and bigoted and sexist
by our standards today we still will not
find him
either we can choose to see historical
figures in the context of their time
judge them accordingly celebrate them
for the great things they achieved while
choosing not to emulate whatever evil
they committed
or we can systematically go back through
time and condemn
every person who's ever lived and all of
our ancestors who established fought for
and passed down to us
every good thing we have in our lives
the left has chosen its path and it's
one that leads
nowhere but to insanity
as you just saw and that is why the
falls church school board
is canceled with a vengeance everybody
else
attacks our histories history tears down
statues monuments takes names off of
buildings
all canceled thomas jefferson though is
not canceled
no matter how much they try to do it
they won't succeed
you know why because thomas jefferson
achieved something
that that withstood the test of time
he did something he changed the world
these people on the school board are
doing nothing they're not going to be
remembered they're not even remembered
now
you could be in the room with them and
you'd forget they were there that that
that that's how that's how utterly
vacuous they are not thomas jefferson
anyway so that's why they're canceled
and we will leave it there today thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton